الى السودان وفي الوسط الجامعي قرار اثر
ضجه كبيره عميت كليه القانون بجامعه
نيلستند الى اللائحه تعود للعام 2011 قرر
منار ارتداء الملابس الضيقه والشفافه وحضر
ايضا ارتداء طالبات للبنطال كذلك يمنع
القرار قصات الشعر الغريبه وايضا الجلباب
بينما يسمح لهم بارتداء الزي السوداني
كاملا النقاش انتقل من اركان حرم الجامعه
الى منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
مع ارتفاع الاصوات المناديه بالحريات
وتقابلها اصوات تدعوا للالتزام داخل
الجامعه الزميل الريان الظاهر زارت مباني
الجامعه واعاده هذا الثقيل
ردود وافعال الواسعه اثرها قرار اداري
لجامعه الينا السودانيه استند فيها على
لائحه تعود للعام 2011 تدعو الطلاب
للالتزام بالمظهر العام الذي ترى الجامعه
انه يتوافقون مع الاعراف والتقاليد
السودانيه
[موسيقى]
او الازياء الضيقه يحرمهن من الدخول الى
حرم الجامعه كما دعت الجامعه طلابها
للابتعاد عن الحلاقات الغريبه وعدم ارتداء
الجلابيه السودانيه القرار الصادرون من
عميد كليه القانوني بجامعه لين اثار جدلا
واسعا وتناوله الطلاب بين مؤيد ومعارض
الكلام ده صح انه ما تكون فيه هدوم ضيقه
لازم تكون في ملابس اطفال
اقرا الاخر من الجامعه تنزل لمواضيع اكثر
من كده وتحاول تعالج المشاكل انك جميله
والحاجات دي انا بعيط قرار توحيد الذي
يجعل الطالب مميز في حتى في الطريق بيكون
طالب مميز بانه تاب الايام
وبكون محترم نفسه يعني مؤيد لبس لذلك
بيكون يعني محترم نفسه في الطريق وفي اي
مكان
زي طالما انه زي ما خلى بالضابط تحت
الجامعه
انا مع القرار بتاع همم اللي هو همم حظر
زي الفاضح
ولانو نحنا اول شيء مسلمين نمره واحد نمره
اثنين الدوله مسلمه 90% من الطلبه
والطلبات مسلمين بالذات جامعه اسلاميه
وفيها العلمانيه فيها بسيطين القرار ده
بيؤيد عن تقاليدنا وثقافتنا وديننا
واخلاقنا لانه صراحه الان الناس الظاهره
اكثر من اللازم يعني معقول
مثل هذه اللوائح تقدمت واصبح من اللازمين
تحديثها لاختلاف الاجيال ويسدد اخرون ان
الجامعه صرح تعليمي ومن لائق الالتزام
بالمظهر والسلوك المعتدل الريان الظاهر
لصباح العربيه الخرطوم
تشكر ريان على هذا التقرير والي مناقشه
وينضم الينا من الخرطوم الجامعي دكتور عبد
الصمد علي عبد الصمد دكتور يسعد صباحك
اهلا بك شكرا على تواجدك معانا في صباح
العربيه نحاول ان نفهم اكثر القرار القرار
مبني على لائحه جامعيه لعام 2011 لماذا
صدوره اليوم تحديدا
وعليكم السلام ورحمه الله وبركاته
صباح الخير صباح الامل صباح التفاؤل
عبر قناه العربيه التحيه للجميع
اقول وبالله التوفيق حتى تتضح الرؤيا همم
انا استاذ بجامعه السودان للعلوم
والتكنولوجيا معهد العلوم والبحوث
الاسلاميه
واستاذ في العديد من الكليات الخاصه
لكن القرار احسب انه قرار موفق ابتداء
لانه يراعي كما تفضل للابناء الطلاب
والطالبات للعرف ومعروف ان من مصادر
الشريعه الاسلاميه
اااه العرف المعروف في عرفا كالمشروط شرطا
والعاده محكمه
وكذلك يعني
كثير من الناس يظنون ان هذا الامر فيه
اضطهاد لحقل المراه
ولعل ديننا الاسلام الحنيف هو انصف المراه
ايما انصاف يكفي ان سوره كامله في القران
الكريم تسمى سوره النساء و ديننا دين
الوسطيه همم وكذلك جعلناكم امه وسطا
لتكونوا شهداء على الناس ويكون الرسول
عليكم شهيده بعض الناس قالوا ان المراه لا
تخرج اطلاقا من البيت بعض المتنطعين الذين
لا يفهمون الدين فهما صحيحا
وشوهوا سوره الدين والتدين والاسلام
وبعضهم قال تخرج متى الاسلام
خروج المراه خروج المراه عموما الشرط
الاساسي له همم عندنا كمسلمين قضيه الحكمه
وعلى القران الكريم يحدثنا عن بنت همم
قالت ان ابي يدعوك ليجزيك اجر ما سقيت لنا
طيب سترد عليك
يسعد صباحك الدكتور يرى ان هذا القرار
موفق ويراعد العرس ما رايك
في البيت صباح الخير عليكم جميعا مشاهدي
العربيه
والقائمين على قناه العربيه
انا اريد ان اتحدث في محورين هو قال انه
من في الاسلام الزي المحتشم انا ارى ان
الفئه التي تريدون ان تحددوا لها الزي هذه
فئه المراهقين اللي هم في الاساس فئه
قائمه على التمرد لانها في هذه السن هي سن
التمرد فانت اذا انت تريد ان توفر همم لبس
محترم ما ممكن تلزم همم الطلاب بلبس زيت
موحد ولكن يمكن ان تضع الليائح وضوابط على
اثرها الناس تلتزم بلبس الزي معين يرضي كل
همم كل همم الفئات
هذا في في
الشئه الثاني في البلده الثاني
الطلاب الجامعات هم في فتره تكوين هويه هم
في فتره تكوين هويه
تكوين هويه الطالب تبدا من من لبسه في
الثانويه
انا باكون مع توحيد الزيت لانه الاطفال في
السن ده المفروض يكون انت بتوريه وبتربيه
وانه كل الناس واحد ما في فرقات اجتماعيه
لما يصل مرحله المراهقه ومرحله الجامعه هو
بيكون اوريدي تاسس على الحاجه دي لكن لازم
يعرف انه كيف اقدر اختار لبسه كيف يشوف
الناس بعيون مختلفه كيف يقرر نفسه شخصيات
الناس لان شخصيات الناس بتظهر بصوره كبيره
جدا من طريقه لبسهم بين طريق يعني اللبس
حتى لو هو مكان بشكل 100% من شخص انت
البني ادم ولكن بيديك هند بيوريك انه
البني ادم ده كيف تفكيره كيف شكله كيف ال-
ال- ال-
اللي هو جاي منها وثقافته في اشخاص اخرين
بيقولوا انه من ناحيه بتاعه همم زي ما
بنقول انه همم الفروق بتاعه همم الطبقات
انه لازم الناس كلها تكون بتظهر بشكل انها
كلها طبقتها واحده ان الناس عموما ربنا هي
ما خلقه واحده غير كده بالعكس انا مثلا في
شخص ضعيف لما كنت في اولى جامعه وقسي بعد
ما تخرجته اشتغلتها طريقه لبس يتغير طريقه
تفكيري تغيرت لانه بقيت مواد بالعكس لو
شفتها زعلت عني لابس بطريقه جميله بيكون
حابه انه انا اكون منسقه اكتر لملابسي
بشكل احسن طيب طيب
انقل هذه الافكار للدكتور عبد الصمد
يعني الشباب اليوم هذا القرار موجه للشباب
الشباب الشباب
كيف يمكن اجبارهم على زي موحد من الافضل
كما قالت زينب ان يتم وضع ضوابط ولوائح
تحترم الادب العامه في الجامعه فقط
اقول للاخت الكريمه زينب همم ردا على
النقطه الاولى ان الطلاب في مرحله
المراهقه ومرحله التمرد تحيه للاخوه في
قناه العربيه لتحرير هذا الخلاف بهذه
الطريقه
العلميه والمنهجه ابتداء وبتديت هذه
الحلقه باستطلاعات من الطلاب انفسهم
وانا لم اكن استاذ لهم او دريسهم
ولم يكن لتنسيق معه وانما معظم
الاستطلاعات كانت تؤيد هذا الراي همم
وتقول انه يراعي العرف وان الاحتكام يتسم
همم مع الصفات السودان
والهويه السودانيه والتقاليدنا وثقافته
النقطه الثانيه
ان توحيد ال ال الزي يكون فيه عدم
المباهى
وكذلك يشعر الناس بقضيه الوحده ارى ان هذه
هي ردت فيها بنفسها على نفسها انه توحيد
الزي بالدين وحده في الشعور وحده في يعني
الانتماء للجامعه كما اشار ايضا احد
الطلاب ولعلك كثير الان من الكليات الخاصه
فضلا على الجامعات الرسميه وحدت همم زيها
والدراسي ولا نرى حرجا في ذلك ولا نراه ان
طعام ايضا من الطلاب في ذلك بالاضافه الى
ان قضيه همم العرف انا واصل لها ايضا حتى
من القران القران يحدثون عن بلقيس همم
ملكه سبا كانت كافره وكانت تعبد الشمس لكن
لان طبيعه العرف محكمه اييي كانت ترتدي زي
طويلا وفضفاضا بدليل انها لما صنع لها
سليمان العرش كشفت عن ساقيها قيل انه صرح
ممرض من قوارير هيقول لها نزلي ثوبك ما في
فاعود
بالصدمه الحضاريه واسلمت وامنت طيب زينب
يقول ان الطلاب
ما رايكم
لا هنالك شريحه كبيره جدا من الطلاب ضد
هذا القرار في المبدا الاول في المبدا
الثاني ويقول انه هما هو فعلا هو فيها
توحيد
للطبقات ولكن الحياه الجامعيه هي تجربه
للحياه العمليه للحياه عموما احنا لما
نطلع للحياه لقدام ما حنكون لابسين كلنا
نفس الزي في الشغل في غيره بتوريك انه لكل
مقام مقال لكل مكان بتقدر تلبس اي اي فينت
او اي اا دعوه او اي مكان ليه تقاليد وليه
ولبسه المعين بشكل معين بيوريك كيف اصلا
تفرز وين تلبس شروق وتلبس كاف ده الحاجه
الاولى الحاجه الثانيه
هم بيقولوا انه التكاليف للزي همم الموحد
بتكون اقل على كاهل على كاهل همم اهل
الطلاب ابدا احنا كان في الجامعه معانا
بناتهم بسيطه جدا جدا لكن بيلبسوا ولبس
جميل وممكن يلبسوا لعبه اه فوق فوق يعني
فوق فوق الملابس وشكلهم جميل جدا فهي
الحاجه يعني حتى اوكي الدين اكيد لكن انت
عايش في بلد انا جريت في جامعه فيها
دايفير ستي كبيره جدا جدا فيها مسيحيين
فيها فيها همم جنسيات كثيره جدا انت ما
بتقدر تحكم الناس كلها اللي زي معايد
بعدين ازاي في حاجات هو بيتكلم من ناحيه
اسلاميه الناس حتى بعد الزي الموحد بتلقى
الناس هم غيروا في المعالم الزي الموحده
بتعطيهم اداره الجامعه سواء كان تضييق او
غيرهم وهم في النهايه لانه هما زي ما قلت
فئه متمرده في هذه السن فهما بينادوا
بحريتهم لانه اختارهم بشكل لبس لان هم
عايزين منه فانا زي ما قلت ممكن تاخذ
اللوائح والضوابط هل انت عايزه كمؤسسه لكن
ما بتقدر تلزم الطلاب بالزيت معينه شكرا
جزيلا
شكرا لك زينب عمر ونشكر كذلك الدكتور عبد
الصمد علي عبد الصمد شكرا جزيلا لكم